o equilíbrio é um estado sistema cujas
forças que sobre lavagens contrabalançam
e celular não entre si de maneira mútua
ora isto é aplicável é todas as áreas da
nossa vida se vão servir e proteger como
essa precisa aplicável quando andamos
mas pararam quando demos um passo à
frente em treinos logo henrique livre e
temos que balancear o peso do corpo até
lá pra equilibrar na e portanto de
imediato existe aqui 11 equilíbrio que é
compensado indiretamente pelo equilíbrio
e ensina as nossas vidas e nas nossas
vidas também todas as áreas da nossa
vida quando em todas as áreas da nossa
vida e com a vida que temos hoje em dia
que muita gente passava seus dias é
tentar equilibrar a vida profissional ea
vida familiar a vida pessoal ea vida
social
temos trabalhos muito exigentes e nós -
então acabamos sem ter trabalho esse ano
chegar a casa tem tratado os filhos ter
que ser donas de casa e temos que ter um
mix também ter uma vida social e tudo
isso é um equilíbrio constatar sempre
umas maria que está um caso um pouco de
equilíbrio e que nós vamos ter que
equilibrar e o que há uns anos atrás
quando lançarem é a minha marca que na
altura foi pioneiro trabalhava em uma
multinacional em pintar e tinha um cara
responsabilidade para além de se lançar
ea marca e abre várias lojas e para além
disso tirei o curso real kate terá uma
certificação em nutrição
tanto que nesta sexta três atividades
profissionais ao mesmo tempo e para além
deles tinha quatro filhos estavam em
casa domingo tinha é fazer exercício
físico tem uma vida social tem amigos
com quem dava e conseguia ter uma
alimentação equilibrada e havia muita
gente perguntava como conceitos como é
que consegue ter esse equilíbrio e
olhando para trás a imagem que o time
que eu tava sempre todos os dias era um
desafio para equilibrar porque havia
sempre tanta coisa
'ser e havia sempre alguma área de
convivência equilíbrio portanto meu
desafio é tentar equilibrar todas as
áreas mas é verdade que eu olho para
trás e conseguir conseguir lançar a
marca que hoje em dia é uma marca do
sesc ou se praticar o meu real de cautín
conseguir os meus filhos fossem a vida e
sair tem chama ter bastante sucesso
iêdo taklin jahvai importante mas o que
eu queria transmitir este que ter um
equilíbrio e desequilíbrio um constante
em tudo nas nossas vidas e eu gostar
também na alimentação não é porque o nós
vivemos num monte chez e o chesta também
na alimentação
isto é não só por causa das nossas vidas
de de estresse corria é que muitas vezes
recorrem chora produtos embalados e
produtos já já preparados com poucos
nutrientes que nos alimentam de maneira
muito deficitária ou então por que
entraram não entrar numa época em que a
alimentação saudável tá na moda tanto
começou a aparecer em jerez também na
alimentação saudável além das dietas que
nós queremos
hoje em dia fala-se muito das dietas x
liga das dietas powell do cruzeirista
todas elas têm muitos benefícios mas
todas elas têm um 30 mil em
fundamentalismo muitas vezes e quem
pratica uma dieta vegan é muito bom
porque realmente reduza a quantidade de
proteína animal destaca ingerir nestas
pensar se o seu organismo está preparado
para uma dieta fiquem sem proteína
animal e o que podemos fazer para
compensar a falta de proteína animal tem
tudo isso tem que ser pensado
equilibrado e hoje em dia surgiu uma
doença que já começou a ser falada que a
ortorexia que a opção pela alimentação
saudável hoje em dia tão surge muitas
pessoas principalmente nas camadas mais
jovens que são o buscadas por aquilo que
comem por controlar aquilo que comem
perceber todos os ingredientes de todos
os elementos que geram e que não
conhecem não querem
nenhuma saída linha querem sempre comer
uma alimentação mais saudável que a este
é um equilíbrio também é mãe também ser
importante nós temos no sal que o que
todas essas dietas todas estas
movimentações muito saudáveis também
podem gerar um ciclo líbio é que a usar
foi feito um estudo pela national
geographic seu site chamada inclusão não
sei se vou seja saibam vocês conhecem e
isso foi bastante falado divulgado e há
mesmo um livro sobre isto em que foram
estudadas quais as zonas do planeta que
tinha uma ementa que tinham um elogio
virado maior e descobrir se estas cinco
zonas do mundo onde realmente a
população pensava o sean anos muitas
vezes mas pensava com uma qualidade de
vida muito boa temos pessoas de 90 e de
80 anos a fazer exercício é ter uma vida
normal disse mas ele frisa como foi ver
com os amigos se com um rácio de doenças
muito muito baixo e esta equipa foi
pressa jonas e perceber o que se passava
ali qual é a diferença porque está com
se o que nós na sociedade nas sociedades
mais x evoluídas não é entre aspas o que
queríamos fazer para poder ter também
essa qualidade de vida que eles tinham e
eu sou listar uma série pencil nove
fatores que os listaram mas
principalmente base uma vida equilibrada
e uma alimentação equilibrada e que uma
alimentação equilibrada nesta zona
nestas jonas é basicamente não comer
produtos processados como uma próxima da
natureza
primeiro com a natureza local onde está
tanto pouca carne muita as digitais
fazer exercício físico regularmente e
comer moderadamente comer e beber
moderadamente todos bem vindo e também
mas tudo em quantidades moderadas
portanto isto pois placar outros fatores
porto está interligada não é ter uma
vida social ativa tem um propósito para
salvar
da cana mexe o regulamento o principal
em termos físicos ou esta vida e
alimentação equilibrada e e egito têm os
que nós podemos aprender e pensar um
bocadinho
o que nós podemos fazer é ter uma
alimentação equilibrada e o que eu trago
aqui hoje e é o que eu penso que são os
trechos
os três já têm regras básicas que eu
acredito que se conseguirmos podemos ter
uma alimentação realmente equilibrada e
são elas como próximo da natureza seria
bastante e ouvir o nosso organismo e
agora esperando que ele pondo em prática
o que como é que nós fizemos isso no
nosso teatro e ator é fato não é
constante por comer próximo da natureza
como a próxima da natureza implica
evitar os os alimentos mais processados
tanto optar um segundo princípios tais e
fruta em todas as nossas refeições dos
alimentos frescos e ganhamos e evitarmos
ao máximo os alimentos muito
transformados e os alimentos não
transformados o que são
no funchal que gosta de algo quer comer
iogurte com august gordo em algo natural
que seus magros tirem os marcos da nossa
alimentação um alimento magro e um
alimento que foi transformado que foi
tirado ao inserir outros para dar sabor
e consistência que são os autores à
lactose
esqueçam leite sem lactose eleito papa
em outubro era quinto era lá e que não
tolera light não vê lá e que
simplesmente há uma data de outras
coisas da natureza clique que podemos
comer não é preciso e nos comer esses
alimentos transformados
é importante conciliar os por exemplo as
filiais e evitar os cereais refinados
optar pelo cdc cereais integrais
os cereais refinados com sabem são
transformados são inspirados camadas do
serial se inspirar no trio
sei que muitas vezes comemos bastante
passado mas agora estamos com fome
porque não conheço os nutrientes com o
nosso corpo precisa captar os parciais e
integrais arroz integral massa farinhas
integrais ao princípio podemos achar um
caso estranho mas rapidamente nosso
corpo se habitua depois ao açúcar não é
o açúcar que esse bicho papão e privado
é o bicho-papão porquê porque eu sou
branco que está em maior parte dos
alimentos e eles chefes sem exagero nós
optarmos promessa pra optámos por super
cana é com conta peso e medida da oea
são os alimentos que também tem muitos
edifícios têm muitos nutrientes
importantes podemos com meus com a
oração e fé nos sentir esses benefícios
do nosso organismo
a segunda regra feriado bastante
variáveis tais como é que nós podemos
variar
primeiro que tudo e com menos de uma
forma sazonal respeitadas as finalidades
dos nossos produtos durante o inverno
por exemplo e pensar de conhecermos um
cadinho é que os produtos que são os
produtos de gestação e também os
produtos locais
os produtos que são produzidos aqui
localmente no sítio nós vivemos faz toda
a diferença e é verdade que agora
ouvimos falar filhos os blogs de
alimentação as revistas e falas macaé
caiu falasse naquela minha avó me a
vossa vida eu queira caiu
aquela é uma cor além dos estados unidos
sim senhora tá na moda mas já temos
essencial nós temos o conflito guesa
temos as beldroegas temos uma data do
desfile - que estão aqui que às vezes
uns nascem no canal nas estradas por
onde passaram na beira da estrada e
podemos comer se tem taxas são mais
nutrientes do que do primeiro recado que
vem do outro lado do mundo
o presente agora o xarope de gás também
está na moda 15 não chegou a pegar
chopperias nunca tinha ouvido falar
se não há cinco ou seis anos atrás temos
mel fantástico em portugal temos um uma
variedade enorme altura podemos até usar
o tablet para os nossos novos elementos
têm tanto nós tínhamos esta evolução é
esta eu queria um bom senso e não
existir grande
- é só seguir o cadin estas regras e pi
e optámos por aquilo que temos no sítio
onde vivemos
depois por último o ouvir o nosso corpo
ouvir o nosso corpo a muitas das minhas
clientes que chegam a permitir a mas
como é com o suporto como é que eu posso
para tentei muito fácil pra já temos
comçar é é é desenvolver essa capacidade
de ouvir o nosso corpo e o cortar os
resposta para tudo
a primeira técnica e nós fazemos um
diário alimentar nós que vemos
diariamente tudo que comemos e
registadas como 1 cêntimos para já
ficamos como a consciência e vamos ter
surpresas fantásticas umas boas outras
menos boas que realmente com eles um que
nem exageros nisso nós sejamos naquilo e
isso vai ajudar uma consciência muito
muito grande
depois vamos ver vamos perceber como é
que nós por reais é determinados
alimentos e perceber se ele me
interromper nosso jornal porque o
alimento que é bom pra mim pode não ser
bom com vocês podem até podem ver te
dizer que é muito saudável que faz nem
isto ou aquilo
o meu corpo pode não durar e é preciso
nós respeitamos isso acima tudo é isso
sim é e que tal equilíbrio ea verdade é
que hoje em dia ou se situa a multilog
da alimentação
há muitas outras finalistas e muitas não
defini se escrever sobre alimentação e é
verdade que muitas no outro dia uma
criança assim como cinco paradas por dia
porque é uma droga que ela sempre já não
podia ver bananas e muitas janelas quase
que sejam como cinco bananas por isto é
uma questão de bom senso não pode fazer
vai comer cinco bananas podia ajudar
pela minha experiência que vai reter 30
uram se que hoje em dia fazem bastante
se vocês forem ver os resultados que dão
são somos integrantes a que os alimentos
que comemos todos os dias aumenta o
nosso corpo foi primeiro alimento de
todos os dias a falar de até paulo 1o
mesmo alimento todos os dias é de até
paulo por exemplo está muito na moda
agora que abbas carne e desmente cds
tais ajude as pessoas que seguem como
encaro todos os dias a toda hora adianta
paula pau é uma dieta é chamada dentro
do paleolítico no paleolítico eles
pensavam animais comiam carne exatamente
ainda não que ainda não tinha é é
preciso da agricultura mas comiam carne
enquanto caçavam animais pontualmente
não comia nós cá agora quem é paulo eu
colocar uma pequena moça a moça jantar a
saia com o cara toda hora porque não faz
sentido e muitos tenham bom senso e
equilíbrio que nós temos que o fazer
portanto o vosso corpo e acreditem no
que o vosso corpo diz porque e alguns
realmente e ao que vocês têm a vossa não
se pode dizer que estão a seguir o
caminho certo e no fim e queria
finalizar por dizer que nós com o
conseguimos um equilíbrio também com
constante equilíbrio a nossa vida e este
desequilibrar o desequilíbrio não é
também importantes nós fazemos as
mineiras em fazemos nada sem culpa e
hoje à noite e sábado vamos sair demos
um caminho mais encostar depois nós se
equilibrarem suas mas amanhã temos uns
tais manhã temos por um carinho por ela
partidárias intoxicar do álcool e ii e
pronto lá temos nós voltarmos ao nosso
equilíbrio skins ensino em frente e por
isso eu trouxe quis terminar com esta
frase silva participaram que eu gosto
muito e acho que finaliza íris um bahia
que o que eu venho traseira que portanto
a vida é constante equilíbrio do
desequilíbrio não é nós conseguirmos
aceitar os que às vezes equilibradas mas
que é importante nós tivemos como voltar
o equilíbrio em seguir em frente e
obrigada
[Aplausos]